le PCL est une nouvelle de passion civique américaine est
tombée encore plus
défaite de Sergey lors de la pré-comp à domicile La Paz
américaine Patricia d'abord nous ferons
tout ce que nous pouvons pour récupérer
patty maman papa je vais bien
j'ai eu quelques égratignures et  des trucs mais euh
ils les ont lavés et ils vont
bien et j'ai attrapé un rhume mais ils
me donnent des pilules pour ça et donc je ne suis pas
affamé ou battu ou inutilement
effrayé
[Musique]
un professeur incroyable je  suis évidemment
en vie après avoir subi un lavage de cerveau, l'idée
est ridicule au point d'être au-delà de
toute croyance et je vais quitter un
dire que je suis étonné que vous pensiez que la première
chose que je veux faire
le fait est que je m'en fiche  si jamais je
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Je pense qu'elle est le facteur critique dans
ce cas, son état d'esprit est la
chose à laquelle elle seule a accès
[Musique]
Je pense que c'était  tout cela parce que j'étais
Patricia Hearst, je veux dire, si j'étais personne,
rien de tout cela ne serait arrivé et vous
savez, en plus, c'était un procès très déroutant
aussi